the reason i did what i did at
microstrategy was
if i gave the 500 million dollars back
to the shareholders
that was 60 a share the stock was 120 a
share
i basically was valued at one times
revenue plus the cash
when i gave the money back to the
shareholders the stock was going to go
to 60 a share when that happened
all my employees stock options were
going to be underwater
right um and
we were going to get beat to death
by amazon apple facebook and google
they're just going to steal all our
employees when the stock crashed and
that would mean that instead of growing
five or 10 percent a year i was going to
be shrinking five or ten percent a year
instead of my cash flows doubling or
tripling they were going to be cut to
zero
and once your revenues start falling
your cash flows go to zero you have no
capital all your employees quit when
your employees quit the company unwinds
we're going to go to zero
so giving the cash back to the
shareholders was a fast death
holding the cash at zero percent
interest when it was losing 20 percent
of its value a year was a slow death
doing something was the alternative and
so
we decided to do something which is
invest the money in a property or in an
asset that would go up faster than the
rate at which the money was collapsing
and that set us on a search and we
considered buying a portfolio of scarce
art
i thought about 500 million worth of
real estate really you thought about uh
mine art yeah
i thought everything do you buy gold do
you buy art do you buy real estate do
you buy a portfolio of stocks
before you settled on bitcoin you were
thinking art you're thinking real estate
you're thinking anything other than
cash everything in fact in fact we put
out a press release to our entire
shareholder base when the stock's 120
and you can go read it today it said
over the next 12 months we're going to
buy back 250 million dollars worth of
our stock and we're going to invest 250
million dollars worth of our treasury
assets and some
some asset in order to avoid inflation
and we listed a litany of these things
and we included bitcoin as one of the
things we're evaluating
um
ultimately so so we went from first
principles we said
you have a bunch of money
and i'll tell you why we said we're
going to buy about 250 million of our
stock in a second uh but you have a
bunch of money say 250 million dollars
you want to hold it for 100 years give
it to your great grandchildren where do
you invest it
well if you put it into the dollar the
dollar is losing at least it's been
losing seven to ten percent of its value
a year for a hundred years
that means over the course of a hundred
years the dollar loses 99 percent of its
value
my house in miami beach was purchased
for a hundred thousand dollars in 1930.
okay i bought it for 14 million dollars
this is the village 2012.
today
you know yeah so
100 000 to 50 million
in less than a hundred years that's
that's not the house getting more
valuable that's the currency getting
less value that means the 200 million a
hundred years from now is
nothing two million bucks
okay if you took a if you took any
amount of money take 100 million dollars
in the year 1900 and invested in any
currency in the world
you would have lost
100 of your money in every currency
except for the dollar or maybe the pound
every currency collapse the winner of
every war in the 20th century was the
united states
and so the winning currency loses 99.5
percent of its value everybody else you
lose everything
now if you if you put that money in gold
there's a 95 chance it would have been
seized
in the hundred years because there's
only a couple cities on earth maybe
zurich or geneva where you wouldn't have
had it stolen and maybe then they still
would have stole it you know if you were
the wrong citizen
um in the wrong country if you were a
swiss citizen in switzerland for the
hundred years you might have kept gold
but
you know
churchill sees the goal roosevelt sees
the gold if you'd lived in germany you
would had your gold seized multiple
times in japan they lost it two or three
times and russia
you know count the number of times so
there's nowhere on earth where you could
have kept your uh your gold
and now you're stuck with okay well
where do you invest it land
take um
take a hundred million dollars worth of
money and buy land in florida
tax bills two million dollars a year
if you buy property in florida's two
percent property tax a year it gets
assessed up every year you have the
ownership of the land for about 20 years
before the government takes it back from
you
you you don't own you don't own your
yeah uh the maintenance so
if you want to move money through time
how do you do it you can't do it with
the currency
the money is broken the money was always
broken it's been broken for 100 years
losing seven to ten percent of its value
but
in hyper-inflating economies like
venezuela argentina
fill in the blank
the money uh loses twenty thirty forty
percent of its value a year sometimes
eighty percent of its value a year
in that case you can't even carry money
for a decade you might not be able to
hold money for a year in those economies
uh the russian ruble's lost 35 percent
of its value in the past
few weeks
right that's how fast it collapses
so
fundamentally we have this issue i want
to move money through time i have a 100
year time frame i'm an institution the
whole point of this institution's
supposed to go on right and so
how do you do it
no currency will work can you use gold
well gold is money is is the best idea
humanity had for like 5 000 years but it
was but it's not a perfected idea the
problem with gold is gold miners produce
two percent more gold a year
okay
that's no better than the state of
florida seizing two percent of your uh
your property a year in a property tax
the half-life of gold therefore becomes
about 30 years you divide two percent
into 70 in 35 years your money's cut in
half
hold it for 100 years it's cut in half
three times
the second problem is it'll be stolen by
a criminal
or politician that disagrees with you
and the third problem with it is that
gold is a property you have to put in a
vault and if you have to put in a vault
then the counterparty the bank is able
to hypothecate it and re-hypothecate it
which means they basically sell
a hundred ounces of gold paper for every
ounce of gold you hold and they keep
they keep shorting it naked and they
hold the price down and manipulate the
price
you can't hold your own gold
so
ultimately the problem with gold is
holding money in gold over the course of
a hundred years is going to lose 85 to
90 percent of your wealth under the best
of case
the other problem is
you can't move money through space
with gold i need to i need to move money
through time and space i need to hold it
for 100 years and i need to move it from
here to tokyo
if i want to move
you know
a billion dollars of gold is like 30 000
pounds or something you want to move a
bunch of money through space it's gonna
cost you three to six months and five
million dollars to move it once
if you want to move it through time
you're going to lose 80 90 percent of
your money through time
and it's going to be seized so
gold's a pretty expensive way to move
money currency is an ineffective way to
move money
property property is only good so long
as the nation state that the property is
in chooses to allow you to continue to
possess it
but of course uh the oldest you know the
oldest story in the world is oh we lost
the family farm because we couldn't pay
the property taxes
you can hold the price you can hold the
land
you know buy 10 000 acres of land
someone moves in and sets up shop next
to you they incorporate a city then they
bring 50 people in the city then they
make themselves mayor then they pro pass
a property tax then they annex your farm
then they give away free money to
anybody that wants free housing in the
city then they double your property tax
you can't pay your property tax then
they seize the property because you
can't pay the property tax so
ultimately property is not a very
effective way to hold money for a long
period of time and you can't move money
through space
so
this is a problem
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]